this question as its presented to you
somebody actually who's done this some
of you might have actually done this
because I didn't assign it for something
yeah okay you might recognize it in
their ticket this is a devices inc your
textbook um this is a single part
question in some ways but the question
is trying to sort of hold your hand
through it the textbook brother is
trying to hold your hair so they break
the question apart into three parts ok
now I'm not going to tell you what the
parts are I'm just going to walk through
them and then i'm going to show you the
three part after the fact so you can see
ah this is how you get guided sort of
you know just like a like a wizard for
setting up your email like they then
walk you through step-by-step and the
question very simply is you have a you
have an account okay and it's it's a
code of its fixed in size okay and you
don't have any numbers which is part of
what makes this question challenging
which is why i picking it out as it
available but these could be you know
say for example it could be a current of
radius 10 centimeters and high 20
centimeters okay so you often do get
numbers for this but the fact that there
aren't numbers that their protein rules
is part of the challenge of this
question I'm going to equip you to deal
with this so then within this fixed cone
I've drawn it in blue and like I said
you know colors are a super power okay
I've got a cylinder which can be
different sizes right so long as it's
inscribed I'll try to fit a big cylinder
inside my fixed comb okay you can
quickly see and maybe you want to draw
this off of a sign right just like we
had all our different versions of our
earthly box that you guys follow the
beautiful colorful cardboard right there
are different versions of this cylinder
that exists right of different kinds of
dimensions so draw off on the side of
your page draw me a few codes maybe
maybe three cones
no you don't know i'll show you how I've
drawn my so you've got any codes okay
now here's the way by the way I feel
like I'm not very good at drawing
cylinders and courage it's not that hot
right where it starts with his watching
how big am I gonna make my Susilo duck
now for example you can see how drawn
kind of like a medium silver he wear it
on face it's diana entire roughly the
same but i would have a really really
fat psyllid up something like this so
draw the base of that psyllid i'm right
and once you've drawn the base how big
could have possibly get okay it's
limited by how wide it is right so if
you just take the edges of the silver
drove down to forever they get the car
like that okay it can't go any further
because the careers of fixed science
right so that's you jam it in but that's
as far as it goes and then you draw the
bottom oh you're silly girl right so
then go there's there's not a very
obviously it could be completely flat
right so that's what we're very very
large radius I could have one where it's
a bit yeah a small radius is something
like this so I make it more in between
and then you can see I could draw my
height down further because it's thinner
that makes sense it goes further into
the cone but the whole thing is actually
not as why and that's what him feel
right and then there's an extreme which
is to make a very very thin cylinder or
very small radius something like this
and because so if it could go further
into the comb right so you couldn't draw
down your own draw down your height yeah
and it's going to load pretty close to
the bottom you see that so these are
kinds of what I'm imagining in my mind
for the different versions of this
cylinder that exists within the current
and what I want to know is which what is
the biggest right on cue hey so okay so
she was nervous about 93 grams yeah yeah
they're free foot sir okay
that we as Elizabeth she do you want to
grab oh you wanna grab one more time
okay yeah just telling everyone three
yeah it's fine short conversations oh
it's fine that's okay do you want to
just get the knowledge yes cuz it okay
so here's the setup right here's the
side now how are we going to approach
this and what I'm doing by not giving
you the individual parts of the question
I'm giving it to you in its hardest for
right it's like you need to go from a
all the way to Z and work out all the
parts in the middle okay so I want to
know what's the volume of the biggest
cylinder that can fit in there that's
the question okay so if you want to know
the volume well what kinds of like
trying to reverse engineer go think
backwards what kinds of things are you
going to need to know to get the volume
yes it okay we're gonna well we're going
to need um we're going to need two
dimensions aren't we to actually work
this song because it's a 3d shape and
it's got a radius na hi okay so you're
going to need to know which radius or
height is going to give you the maximum
size right so before this question I
need to do its radius which hi it yes
you see that okay now before that climb
back because I've stated this as I look
you've got two variables you don't
really have two variables do you
remember is me drawing I'll cylinders
this is actually a crucial step that's
why I asked you'd actually do it on
paper before but you can't do always do
it on paper as soon as I determine my
radius right like oh it's really really
fat oh it's kind of in the middle no
it's really thin as soon as you know the
radius you already know the height do
you see that like the radius kind of
defines the height right that's right so
you have two variables what which
depends on the other okay so really it's
one or the other right do what radius or
do you want hi you pick one and then
we'll go from there
so what I'm going to need to do is I'm
gonna have to pick one of these ok now
it's not just because like I said they
do relate to each other that I want to
pick one what's my actual mathematical
reason for why i only want to work with
one of them because when i differentiate
right I'm going to differentiate with
respect to one variable like I'm either
going to differentiate with respect to R
or I'm going to differentiate with
respect to H and I can't do both ok
unless I go to university and do partial
differential equations at University
which you don't want to get to just yet
ok able to do it again too so therefore
I've gotta pick a variable right that
means I've got to do one more thing ok
if I'm going to differentiate something
with respect to our all with respect to
H what am I differentiating I'm going to
have to differentiate the volume right
which means i need the volume in terms
of one of these variables right which i
don't have at the moment ok so now i've
climbed all the way back up right i need
to know the volume of this thing in
terms of one of the variables ok and
then I'm going to take that I'm going to
differentiate and find hopefully a
maximum right then I can use that and
actually work out the volume does that
make sense do you see how I've mapped
out my path in here ok all right let's
be good so firstly I want to say volume
equals and I'm dealing with this blue
wanted here ok so to help you before I
am you know will just write this quickly
down what is the volume of that sooner
hi just PI R squared H right that's just
um that's just a statement ok now before
I go any further I'm just very aware of
the fact that i mentioned this before
then I've got so many potable flying
around this is a trap to dexters need to
jack yep yeah
so here's what you need to do to avoid
the trap right people will get confused
to you know how we said all of this
stuff here people will get confused
about what their functions are in
relation to what variable they are and
therefore what their differentiating
with this vector it's very very
confusing there are four pretty rules
here by four pretty rules to can change
a to cont two can change them to cut in
other words two of them are variables
and two of them are concerts right to
over the numbers can change and two
cards right all right I can say in the
beginning what was the setup right and I
even tried to do it with different
colors so you could see the cone is
fixed it stays put like an ice cream
cone it's like well what can I put in
here I can't just I wish I could make a
bigger but that's just the size of the
code you may pay more than right so
therefore my constants are the
dimensions of the curve which are which
radius in which I it's a lower case
right ah and H loans okay I've got three
variables they are the Capitals right
there the dimensions of the cylinder now
this is freeze like oh I've got big ones
and I've got little ones and I can
distinguish them okay you often won't
get that you'll get like you know say
theater here and then you'll get X a B
and P okay you're like how do I am I
remember which ones which oh this will
be called something even more confusing
which mixes in with the rest ok so this
step here is crucially helpful so you
know what you're talking about and the
number of times I've seen someone said
you differentiate all you with respect
to say in this question say that it's
like but that's a number that's like say
five it's like I'm gonna differentiate
with respect to five how's 585 no
changes okay so this doesn't work and
that's one of the ways i know a student
doesn't understand the question right
they haven't identified what's actually
changing okay now I'm getting to that I
will need to eliminate one of these out
as you can see so that like a different
ship but I'm not quite there yet right
so you're in fact about to do much
except the fact is that H is variable it
changes does it not like you even saw it
changes
okay so i do have to list it out over
here it's a lot of constant